é obrigado a todos muito boa noite é
muito bom estar aqui e você ver que
vocês aguentaram a geração que meia
noite incluindo ainda a questão é muito
obrigado a dar banho em um festival de
música com o modo vilar de mouros o que
tem a ver com um jogo de cartas
são coisas são mundos completamente
diferentes festivais de música vocês
criar mais ou menos todos conhecem já
foram efetivadas quem já foi longe agora
só para levantar o dinheiro foi nada
nada mal na mão e conhece o universo dos
festivais música agora universo dos
jogos de tabuleiro modernos quem quiser
alguma vez foi uma invicta com 11 prisão
lá dois mais algumas vão muito bem dois
mostraram funcionar é primeiro o título
aí está o festival música no baralho de
cartas como é que em film festival um
baralho de cartas nesse mercado
complicado né
[Música]
é é quem é
viola esses filmes el emoção espírito
[Música]
[Aplausos]
i
anderson silva
[Música]
pois é este o mundo dos jogos de
tabuleiro e se calhar foi uma surpresa
para muitos o sítio pra vocês não
tiveram este ano
sim espero que no próximo ano vão lá uns
ficaram curiosos é uma coisa para
crianças não é isso que jorge toledo
viram né crianças pois vocês viram a são
jogos de tabuleiro modernos como este
aqui e ali um funk ganhou e ganhou que
um jogo
eu estive lá como voluntário tinha
também uma camisola laranja com aquela
do grupo nesta fotografia é e não como
voluntário é um evento gratuito nós
somos todos canoas disto queremos é
mostrar às pessoas o que é isto dos
jogos problemas modernos
eu estive lá uns três dias praticamente
a correr de um lado para o outro eu
explicar jogos não só o meu jogo muito
muito tempo para jogar e ainda conseguiu
inscrever na pressa nesse torneio do que
48 é e por várias razões porque é um foi
o jogo foi o jogo com troféus para este
este novo mundo para esta nova geração
a eu tinha a função na americana e agora
tem um significado múltiplo porquê
porque eu sou um apaixonado por um
combóio porque eu aproveitei o pré-mirim
o salário que o que a minha tropa e
[Música]
o meu primeiro enterro depois fiz mais
300 anos morria europa tudo foi assim
quase toda foi assim que eu conhecia era
possível viajar de comboio é gosto tanto
sempre gostei tanto com boss que
enquanto quanto vinha de férias a troco
de antes chamava já viram aí que eu não
tinha um anda minha fogos vazios e
passear de de comboio a ligação aos
comboios também é grande porque em casa
tínhamos uma parte tinha uma grande 11
gols em 91 do sóbis teu era montar uma
lista enorme de boys marco em quem
conheça a função da marca e continuou
[Música]
sim é a marca da internet durante o jogo
da nossa vida
individualista e acho que este é o maior
problema é que nós vivemos foi passamos
por uma era muito mais individualista
muito mais todos nós somos muito mais
egoístas menos solidárias é e tem também
um muito a ver com a associação a nor
socialização
o jogo está o goleiro sobretudo os de
deus com de direção os modernos que eu
vou falar
tem trecho a trecho muito importante e
muito forte uma direção só o primeiro
que tudo para divertir no segundo
interação social nós permitem interagir
socialmente a volta não é um algo
individual e por último treino de
competências
nós estamos sempre um jogo estimula nos
sempre alguma alguma coisa alguma
competência um reflexo pode ser é não
ser mais longe do raciocínio lógica eu
acho que na vida nós precisamos tomar
decisões não há nada como o primeiro
passar por um jogo a mais
entretanto todos dessa primeira geração
este petróleo
alguma vez conheceu este o quarto uma
uma outra editora que também desapareceu
tinha dois grandes shoppings era o
petróleo e era o jogo da bolsa mas
também jogou melhor que as cinco
empresas do machado só tinha quatro para
banho mas também aos jogos de cartas e
mais cartas clássico tenso todos nós
jogamos cartas uns mais outros menos
jogos diferentes e têm dois feridos um
que joga muito e família que
nós chamamos um sobe e desce é e outro é
o quinto
mas quem tem um grande problema é que 24
josé muito difícil encontrar exatamente
quatro jogadores entre os jogos cartas e
um sempre tive muito gosto por esses
jogos de transportes e com boys de
aviões carros etc
esta é uma das muitas cartas de baralho
de cartas que o que eu tenho e tem já
vem e que o é preciso fazer 100 mil e as
cartas já vamos voltar a isto acresce um
jogo mais conhecido o trabalho mais
conhecido há alguns só seis pontos
celulares com razão só vai começar
depois é muito bom é mesmo um chato é
muito específico o objetivo é eu estou à
vontade porque eu fui jogador extra
durante 16 anos mas também chegou uma
altura na vida que isso realmente há
outras coisas mais divertidas do que
isso entretanto em diante desta nova
geração nasceu este o gol a bola não sei
se algum de vocês conhecem jesus go
envolvendo um bala mas mais de vantagem
tal maneira que gostei deste jogo que no
meu clube de xadrez eu postou agentes
ganharam a bola e pois organizarem
torneio nacional arranjei patrocínios
não conseguiu organizar falar com com
editora london mania que infelizmente am
também já jogou em portugal e consegui
ter é ter este é um dos dois criadores
de jogos que trazer o aeroporto para a
apresentação do torneio
a propósito quem tem uma bola agora o
celta é assim né não vale a pena os
ganhos até por isso não porque dá empate
sempre né
não vale a pena foi por isso que o jogo
também escutou e sua vez nunca se j
porque realmente é muito complicado a
uma ligeira vantagem porque ele começa a
seqüência o francês e belga é bastante
mais interessante jogo rio para ser um
jogo bem segunda geração o meu contacto
com a segunda geração dos jogos do
goleiro foi há quatro anos na biblioteca
almeida garrett um sítio extraordinários
cliente tem pena que não tenha voltado
você lá espero que um dia eu volto para
lá um sítio em cavar para se fazer um
encontro de oftalmologia lá com um chute
que atuar no jogo que eu já falei esta
opção original
conheci o chá natal com um jogo
delicioso você é tão pura num monopólio
da oposição já etá nem mesmo nós estamos
sempre a negociar uns com os outros
é triste mas é muito tiro
é o catar e se calhar alguns já conhece
também o catar é mexeu há 20 anos é é
considerado o primeiro o precursor da
nova geração de jogos do blog tem muitas
coisas diferentes novas
os novos jogos de tabuleiro tem muito
poucos estados os primeiros que o que os
representa e não tem esse tem ele em
2008 o tablet é sempre diferente
estas peças você sabe não estão aqui
nunca começou da mesma maneira no jogo
só isso já faz do jogo muito dá um
interesse muito grande a grandes figuras
públicas que jogam catar e suína só que
um jogo ruim disse depois desta nova
geração por ano nascem mais de mil jogos
de tabuleiro são criados em todo mundo e
acho o espiritismo este esplendor é um
dos jogos mais jogados hoje em dia muito
muito interessante também oriente também
istambul uma série de temáticas
diferentes terra forma em março em um
jogo mais jogado neste momento pelos
poemas do porto sul sobre os azuis em
português e foi lançado por um
estrangeiro o marroquino link é um dos
melhores jogos de tabuleiro e foi o jogo
mais badalado na na feira de s
recentemente que é a maior feira de
jogos de tabuleiro do mundo e temos
também jogos português vital a seda o
num conceituado criador do rock
português está no top 100 com dos seus
jogos e 101 foi lançado em simultâneo em
quatro línguas em 4 para esse foi criado
por dois portugueses
criado por um português lançado este ano
é que temos um outro jogo forma te um
xogum sobre corridas de carros é esta
este é o circuito de mônaco este jogo
está fotográfico traga que estávamos dez
a volta do tabuleiro foi foram duas ou
três horas empolgante fantásticas uma
experiência fantástica é a volta de um
jogo popular
a minha primeira criação de jogos de
tabuleiro wanja da juventude juventude
eo irmão carlos
criamos precisamente um jogo de uma
corrida de fórmula 1
depois nunca mais avançamos quando
regresso à moda entre aspas do jogo de
tabuleiro
eu fui desenvolvendo alguns protótipos
algum choque existem 1 em um deus tem um
jogo no futebol é e entretanto em
paralelo desenvolve o jogo de tabuleiro
sobre lado moça tem uma posição muito
forte com
com a aldeia com o festival está há
muitos e muitos anos
é paixão essa tornou bastante mais forte
neste ano de 1982 a andar pouco falava o
meu foi uma experiência marcante para
mim com 18 anos nove dias do festival
vocês estão vendo aqui é uma pessoa
absolutamente única nenhum stival do
país tem um dia que estava com carimbo
do primeiro dia do festival
este é o palco está o palco é é
construir 1 82m e que o bono vox subiu
excluídas da volta o tempo está a acabar
e vamos então entrar nos no jogo
primeiro ouça 11 livro eu lançar um
livro sobre o festival de vilar de
mouros é uns anos é pelo meu gosto gosto
que eu tinha então o festival e até que
em 2014 regressa o festival e é e um dia
estava de férias no algarve ou na páscoa
e vai em aaa a cabeça uma idéia de fazer
um show do tabuleiro
eu uma página consegui criar regras
todas e existe hoje durante três anos ou
muito desenvolvimento muitos testes
dezenas de pessoas participaram nos meus
testes o protótipo do jogo de tabuleiro
mas não tive condições e infelizmente
para lançar ainda não tive condições de
lançar o jogo do tabuleiro conseguir sim
foi lançar o jogo de cartas este ano a
edição deste ano é mais pequeno mas
regras são basicamente os mesmos só não
tem aquelas aqui que tem tem o irmão
tira e eu eo design
eu acho fantástico e acho muito bonito
santa joana manhã cinco grandes
dificuldades na parte final as editoras
mercado porque ainda é muito pequeno não
tinham é não se criam aventurada sun é
criar um jogo popular sobre 11 jogo de
cartas sobre um festival de música
porque são muito muito diferente com uma
aliança que acabamos por confirmar mas
mesmo assim existe e achei que era na
altura do dotal nextep o próximo passo
era e este e com os que lançaram o jogo
e eja com 11 com duas vantagens e com
instrumento primeiro é o jogo está
preparado para qualquer pessoa joga
independentemente de saber ou não saber
nada sobre lado museus o festival não é
possível saber rigorosamente nada para
poder jogar um jogo simples de
colecionar cartas a sete cartas do que
da condição e precisa colecionar e é um
jogo que permite expansões que algo que
jogos modernos têm que é isso de
expansões é mais uns anos mais tarde no
ano seguinte pudesse acrescentar alguma
coisa criar algo diferente é a partir do
original este aqui permite criar a
expansões todos os anos em que haja o
festival está preparado para sem alterar
nada das regras se acrescentarem mais é
cartas na edição 2007 será concretizada
anunciado que sim são mais sete cartas
do jogo e uma pole que aquela catamarã
ou que é sobre o outro passar do tempo e
não é obrigado vocês tenham gostado
[Aplausos]
[Música]